The classic head in is in the name then is not the head an ism of new york or london or paris cairo. Wherever.
But full moon nights and the fruits of on. Delicious for use. I mean. The feast right. Healthy living.
Beautifully prepared and presented. Vegetarian.
Back when one talks of two food and and learned who was as being the food of a non-meat eating culture.
And i can assure you that. We ate well. Me. Home brew and herbal teas. Herbal teas is said to a tingle and.
And of course the duck smoking and that. And the mushrooms and things and.
And certainly in the early days of nimbin that was about that the sum total of any drug taking that.
That that i was aware of and. And i will say this that i grew up. Or i lived in nimbin. For those seventeen knees.
I have lived in those and i. And i was a non smoker. I was you know. To to actually still be amongst some fairly.
Entrenched marijuana users and. I'm not to be a smoker was quite threatening.
I was just allergic to dust and you can get your highs in many many ways. You know that the dancing the blue knob.
And the. And the dances that we used to have a blue note who just had to be experienced.
New year's eve in blue no hole was particularly fat. Fabulous and. The year that.
I like i don't know what you had john. John and sue fox came with welfare state international.
But we built the giant and had the lanterns and that. And the bonfire. It was. It was wonderful.
And that was something that's come of nimbleness is is the celebrations. The sharings both in birth and in death.
We've had our deaths in nimbin. With children and other adults and. And even. Last year almost exactly a year ago.
John and sue folks came to visit to us here in in lismore and. My father had died. The day before they arrived and.
They helped me prepare a celebration of his passing. Which we held here in the garden.
And that was just beautiful and it was.
It was moving on from that the rituals and ceremonies that we've had in my children know.
When that i'm in the naming ceremony. So. Ritual celebration.
May be had in this in head in this it is a hard one it's just delightful. To light food. Delights and earthly delights.
Is how i remember it. And i suppose for perhaps being in the in the mama role. It was my life was somewhat.
Tempered by that. Didn't stop me from dancing like. My pregnant belly off night after night but.
You can see why don't the format. This amazing mess. This. Oh this. And then free and friendship tiny.
And suddenly and i knew rada indian names of which in all names. South american names. All sorts of things.
Ploughs trees. Sita amazing things. I can't remember the name.
The idea of naming the names of the children or finding the names of the children. Was again. Relating to how.
How we felt about where we were and.
Perhaps rejection of the susans in the dark jonson the dieted less and less so and finding names that had meaning.
Many children would name to because of the then meaning of that. That nags. Because there was a strong. Indian tibetan.
American indian influence on the spirituality of the people so that people had you know he taught name still or.
Would his name so south american names. The environmental movement lead. Two children having.
Names of trees and and and animals. So perhaps being.
Being interested in reclaiming different cultures and searching for culture. I think that we. We took him.
Tested out and checked out. All the other cultures that were not. The western white protestant ethic. Anything but.
So you know people. There was the south america there was the american indian there was the the. The indian.
Tibetan buddhist.
All sorts of different cultures which were were examined in looked at and bits were taken from him
but so taken to hear that from that that that. Went up to build that. The culture has developed in this area now.
Oh yes. Yes. Again.
From the sublime to the ridiculous you can only it's like what i was saying before about having to go all the way.
I mean what if you look at these sort of.
You go to some of these conferences and things that they have now these search conferences and. You know that.
The big multinationals and. And the banks and the government and even the public service have now.
And you have to have brainstorms. You know. And in the brainstorms i say. The wildest ideas you've got.
You know all these people who get paid thousands
and thousands of dollars for doing these things these consultancies you know.
Letting go and you know just let your minds go free. And i have the wildest ideas.
And then from there we can find something is only if you let your mind go free
and you let you go to the ultimate that you get something. Solutions some alternative side to use. In the lived it.
You know. This. Well you conferences in your career consultancy. Member lived. Doing that. Things like.
You know we we are allowed to to push the limits you know.
Because it's an about pushing the limits that you actually find something otherwise you live in mediocrity if you.
You know it's sort of like. If you don't.
If you've got to go out a little bit further you're not going to see the value of goods.
So i can't think of any five words i mean. Twenty dozy reckoned her. Hadn't thought about. Funny nimbin story.
Some of the houses..
I mean when you're talking about pushing the limits it's some of the houses that people go to know from from t.p.s. To.
Two houses made out of aluminum plates from from printers. Recycling.
You know just the amazing things that people could do with recycling.
Peter pedals and his and his bicycle technology you know. The idea of of of. You know. Making smoothies.
On a bicycle pedal power. Those stairs things. Then can be refined intend into to really usable things people.
There was that there was a guy who used to go around the streets and.
And wearing dresses and hats from st vinnies and made. Made. Puppets from from twigs and. I can't remember his name.
I mean he was he was eccentric campus up and he. Was he told. Wonderful stories and made people laugh.
And allow that space for the telling the stories. The community. You know. Just just.
Oh you can't have all these people from all these different groups and things coming together and living.
Successful in people who've done it to go. I meet. I'm an aries and so. One of the attributes of an aries is.
Is to be pioneering. To be in on the ground floor of things and. That was what i was. I was.
I did a lot and then been sacked from the game to. This what i did a lot and then been.
And was involved in the setting up of a number of the community groups that.
Organizations activities that is still happening. We talked about birth and beyond.
And i was involved in that and it's very early days. I was involved in the home builders association. In my.
My female capacity. In the community school.
I was in my my children were some of the first hurston children to go to the community school and was.
Was involved in the various committees. That we set up to to get that going.
The co-anchor preschool which isn't nimbin but still run on in the same sort of. Lines. And. Yes.
So a lot of the things that went on there i i like to be.
I was involved in like think that i was there in the early days.
I've been i helped boot who has is the first house was on. Was on. Shad land.
That little iraq with some difference eddie and elspeth. Who i first met in katmandu.
All the world mates and then been to. And. Marcus and i built that house together.
And it was made entirely of recycled materials.
And was very beautiful and mad ideas like we used the poles were made from. Dead trees and.
We thought that because the dead trees had all been eaten up by white hats that we wouldn't have any problems with
white tents so we built the house with poles straight into the ground not wanting to use chemicals
or the like i'm the white hence thought this was just wonderful
and so they used this is that channels to got to to build up and and heavy on the base of the house and.
Eventually sort of. Went back to the yeah. It was a biodegradable hass.
And it was exquisite it was just like hansel and gretel house. Covered in violence and.
My babies grow up that it was beautiful. And the other house that i built was. He's my own title.
In a village in a community. Environment that and that house i designed.
I did all the convincing when i purchased the land i did that myself. I designed it i did the plans.
I hired the services of a builder to do a lot of the work and.
Every morning before i went to work in the public service.
I used to get up at six o'clock and work on the house for two hours.
And then go to work and then come home in the evenings and work on it again. So. Yeah i built. I built.
A lot of that hastert and other people came and helped as well and we had with king basin. And it was lovely.
You would guess what. The challenge is for for the area. Is to find creative.
Responses to the unemployment program problem. The challenge is to not be overwhelmed by despair.
The challenge is to maintain hot for me. Is to maintain hot. You know bureaucracy which is fairly hot less.
So we have very very high unemployment here and. I see that is a possibility with creative.
Responses to that situation to. Again. Keep the spirit of aquarius going i'm finding new ways of doing things and.
And the department is is responding. I've been involved in the training and employment of people in.
Rebirthing yoga training in. Pema culture. In organic farming. There are people making.
Training and setting up an incubator. Business in recycled and. Sound to events to make finishing. Hopefully.
Enterprises like the ramp up our company will. Will grow. In other areas too. So yeah it's. And it's also being.
Being a sort of a media. A mediator between. The bureaucracies.
Which are struggling to come to terms with the idea of the alternative lifestyles and they
and other people in this area too. And they say. And the unemployment problem. Situation. Maybe unemployment.
Can be turned into something other than a problem for you or you. I'm i'm struggling against the use of the.
Of the word hope. Because it kind of smacks of. No hope. So my. My vision. My. My optimism. For women.
Is that it will go on learning from it six. Our experience that that that nimbin. Is not seen as just being limpin.
But is more than. The name and so is the nimbin village in the nimbin community. And then. Aquarius goes beyond that.
That the children that have grown up in and around women will be able to hold in their hearts. And they will.
They will. They will always have that. Even if they. They set aside for a time.
They will always have the name been experienced and they've been growing in their hearts
and they will always be very special and very different. As a result. So that.
That nimbin will will grow up that nimbin will be able to to move into the twenty first. Century.
With the best of what we've learned. And to deal in a compassionate and heart. Filled way. With the problems.
And to acknowledge to satisfy. But to to grab. It's my pleasure. When i saw.